[Aplausos]
desde la década de los sesentas las
pruebas de seguridad en los autos se
hacían con un maniquí el del peso
promedio de un hombre
esto impacto en que las mujeres tengamos
47 por ciento más de probabilidades de
sufrir lesiones graves en un accidente
recién en el 2010 se exigió incluir
maniquíes con el peso promedio de niños
y mujeres
muchas cosas en nuestra sociedad se ha
construido desde una mirada masculina y
creo que un ejemplo del día a día es
cuando pensamos en las oficinas muchas
veces yo llego y veo las mujeres muertas
de frío y los hombres bastante cómodos
esto se debe a que la temperatura
promedio también se halla o del cuerpo
promedio de un hombre
pensemos en nuestro entorno cuántas
mujeres no premios nobel de economía o
ciencias conocen cuántas mujeres
inventoras cuántas mujeres que hayan
estado en los libros de historia a lo
largo de nuestra vida parte de la
cultura como la conocemos se ha
construido bajo esa mirada masculina y
sobre todo priorizando la mirada
en la historia de los hombres
esto también se puede ver en las
empresas y creo que un buen ejemplo para
darlo a conocer es una serie que se
llama mad men
esta serie reúne a un grupo de
publicistas en una agencia de publicidad
en los 60s
en esta oficina trabajan diferentes
hombres que tienen muchas
características en común la mayoría son
blancos usan un saco corbata son además
heterosexuales y además tienen otro
factor en común sus esposas están en
casa ocupándose un rol súper importante
que es la gestión del hogar de alguna u
otra forma el sistema les exige a estos
hombres trabajar largas horas de hecho
muchas veces se quedan hasta las diez
once de la noche y les exige una
presencialidad de extrema además las
pocas mujeres que aparecen en la serie
trabajando tienen un rol el de
secretarias
yo pasa con estas reglas del juego de
esto y ha pasado casi 50 años
en las empresas vemos que hay diferentes
tipos de personas incluyendo mujeres sin
embargo hay algo que no ha cambiado
tanto y son esas reglas del juego y a
qué me refiero con las reglas del juego
pensemos en los horarios de trabajo
trabajamos hasta las 78 de la noche
pensemos en la presencialidad extrema
que todavía nos exigen muchos trabajos
de una u otra forma la cultura de las
empresas la forma como trabajamos al
igual que las pruebas de seguridad en
los altos autos se ha construido bajo la
mirada de los hombres
qué impacto ha generado esto hoy por hoy
las mujeres somos más grabando nos de la
mayoría de las carreras cuando empezamos
a ver qué ocurre en las posiciones más
altas de las organizaciones se piensa
formar algo así como una pirámide y de
hecho las cifras lo reflejan en el perú
sobre el 6 por ciento de directorios
están ocupados por mujeres y solamente
el 16 por ciento de empresas cuentan con
mujeres en puestos de liderazgo
de hecho según el foro económico mundial
la brecha de género se va a cerrar en
217 años
además cuando las mujeres empezamos a
trabajar nos encontramos con una serie
de barreras
una de ellas tiene que ver con el tiempo
las mujeres dedicamos 24 horas a la
semana al cuidado del hogar mientras que
los hombres dedican 26 por otro lado en
el trabajo tenemos 50% más de
probabilidades de sufrir algún tipo de
acoso
en reuniones de grupo la voz de los
hombres suele ser 75% de veces más
escuchada que la nuestra y cuando
llegamos a hablar muchas veces somos
interrumpidas cuando damos nuestra
opinión y somos muy enfáticas nos pueden
decir que somos un poco mandona y
estéticas o que estamos en nuestras
vidas
lo que hoy vengo a hablar tiene que ver
justamente con ese sistema con esas
reglas del juego
y cómo podemos hacer para gestionar las
organizaciones sin que nadie se quede
atrás como dice la onu y creo que una
buena forma de graficar lo es con un
ejercicio que hacemos en la empresa a
cada persona le damos un personaje a mí
me puede tocar por ejemplo el personaje
una mujer madre soltera con tres hijos
que debe salir del trabajo sí o sí a las
seis de la tarde a otra persona le puede
tocar un hombre casado cuya esposa es
ama de casa a otra persona le puede
tocar una persona que sufre alguna
discapacidad a otro una persona trans
los ponemos a todos en fila
y les hacemos una serie de preguntas si
su respuesta es afirmativa
dan un paso para adelante si la
respuesta es negativa dan un paso para
atrás
así que empiezo a preguntarles hoy hay
una reunión que estaba programada a las
dos de la tarde va a durar tres horas
pero último minuto se movió a las cinco
te vas a poder quedar hasta el final
alguna vez te han preguntado en una
entrevista de trabajo si planeas tener
hijos
tu identidad de género es reconocida en
tu empresa
poco a poco empieza a ocurrir esto hasta
el punto que me he salido de la alfombra
de ted y es algo así lo que ocurre en
los ejercicios lo que piensas general es
que se generan estas brechas
quienes quedan adelante tienen algo en
común el privilegio
estas personas suelen ser hombres con
ciertas características y de hecho
cuando vemos las personas que lideran
nuestras empresas suele ocurrir eso la
mayoría son hombres entonces qué podemos
hacer para cambiar este sistema qué
podemos hacer para repensar las reglas
del juego y así nace mi historia con la
cuales hay cuáles es un emprendimiento
social que lo que busca generar
justamente ese igualdad de oportunidades
trabajar con las empresas como agentes
de cambio para ser más inclusivos y
sobre todo para empezar a diseñar
pensando en los extremos
lo que hemos empezado a hacer es
implementar algo así como unos lentes de
género y lentes de género lentes de
diversidad una empresa con lentes de
género promueve que los procesos de
selección no sean no tengan sesgos de
esas formas hace pautas de entrevistas
que aplican para hombres y mujeres una
empresa con lentes de género empieza a
promover la flexibilidad la flexibilidad
incluso para padres y les brinda días
adicionales a ley para licencia de
paternidad considerando que el estado no
lo brinda lo suficiente una empresa con
lentes de género brinda a las parejas
homosexuales los mismos beneficios que
reciben las parejas heterosexuales y
sobre todo una empresa con lentes de
género diseña productos y servicios con
equipos diversos por una simple razón
los consumidores el mundo allá afuera
stivers
esto además trae increíbles beneficios
para las organizaciones no solamente
porque empiezan a tener prácticas para
retener al 50 por ciento de la población
las mujeres sino porque también empiezan
a dirigirse a sus clientes de una forma
mucho más estratégica y así que todas
las personas que trabajan allí estén
mucho más contentas
lo más bonito de esto es que no
necesariamente debemos ser una empresa
para tener lentes de género las personas
también podemos tenerlo a lo largo de
este camino en a de cuales hemos
empezado una serie de acciones entre
ellas el ranking para este ranking mide
como se encuentran las empresas en
términos de equidad de género y
diversidad
en ese sentido medimos cuatro variables
que forman parte de cómo gestionar este
tema por un lado la cultura qué cosas se
están haciendo en términos de
flexibilidad de prevención del acoso de
publicidad por otro lado la gestión de
su talento cómo gestionar sin tener
sesgos por otro lado la estructura
organizacional qué porcentaje de hombres
y mujeres tienen en esta organización y
finalmente su estrategia están pensando
estrategias adecuadas a los diferentes
tipos de públicos
empezamos en el 2015 midiendo a 22
empresas hoy cuatro años después hemos
medido a más de 400 organizaciones en
perú colombia y méjico
este ha sido un proceso de
transformación para mí empecé a cual es
porque me di cuenta que había una
situación que debía cambiar empecé a
trabajar en otras empresas y vi que
había muy pocas mujeres representándonos
y diademas y sufrir situaciones de acoso
y la verdad me dio tanta rabia la rabia
fue mi catalizador en ese proceso conocí
a mi socia mía perdón a quien compartía
conmigo esa rabia y sobre todo no
queríamos esperar 217 años yo creo que
esta rabia puede ser un gran motor hoy
por hoy somos una comunidad de
organizaciones apostando por este tema y
somos cada vez más personas que apuestan
porque sabemos que si queremos tener un
mundo más inclusivo va a ser más rico y
lo que estamos empezando a generar es
que el mundo no se construya bajo una
mirada sino bajo miles de miradas sin
que nadie se quede atrás muchas gracias
[Aplausos]